[Música]
[Aplausos]
tiene que ha tenido problemas para
adaptarse
a los que no levantaron la mano no les
creo mucho porque es un problema que
tenemos casi todos los que si la
levantaron saben lo que se siente el
rechazo de tus compañeros de trabajo o
de estudiantes lo que también saben que
están dispuestos a hacer muchas cosas
para adaptarse
hacemos un molde como estos de moldes de
galletas donde enseñamos solo lo que
nuestros compañeros quieren ver pero no
lo suficiente para ponernos vulnerables
así empiezo a tener amigos eres feliz
tienes platicas invitan a sus casas a
sus fiestas por un tiempo te gusta lo
que eres te gusta enseñarte pero la
verdad es que sólo enseñas lo que tus
compañeros quieren ver de ti
hay un punto llegas a un punto en el que
hasta tus compañeros lo que dicen tus
compañeros y lo que tus compañeros
piensan de tus amigos es más importante
de lo que tú piensas a un punto en el
que lastimas alguien que quieres solo
porque los demás no lo hacen en mi caso
fue dejar al lado a una mía que quería
muchísimo por solo porque las demás
generaciones sentía que no era lo
suficientemente buena o que no encajaba
con este molde de generación perfecta
que habíamos hecho un año después entras
a secundaria que ahí empieza el proceso
de etiquetas están las matadas las mías
guapísimas que les dicen que no pueden
ser inteligentes los niños course y los
niños lindos que ni son matados ni son
cursos y muchísimos grupos de los que
probablemente no te das cuenta por un
momento piensas que tienes que ser lo
que tus compañeros te dicen porque
piensas que solo así vas a tener una red
con un reconocimiento de ellos que te
van a ver y van a decir bueno es matada
entonces es más importante mantener esta
apariencia mantener lo que piensan sus
compañeros que se lo que eres tú
se crea una burbuja de tensión social
donde todos esperan que se queden en sus
moldes de galletas y que nadie salga
el año pasado nos dividimos uno se
quedaron en méxico otros se quedan se
fueron a alemania yo me fui a un
internado al norte de alemania de mano
marina donde conocí a las personas más
increíbles del mundo con problemas de
depresión problemas familiares y
problemas de autoestima
aún así ellas son mis amigas
aún así tomaron esta oportunidad para
romper esos moldes que se habían hecho
en sus casas en sus familias en la
escuela y tomaron esta oportunidad de
reinventarse de ser ellas mismas
yo intenté seguir sus pasos
pero no es fácil porque llega un punto
en el que tú crees que tu molde eres tú
no lo que hay adentro de la galleta
es muy difícil saber qué es lo que
realmente por eso les pido público los
invito a que salgan de su burbuja social
a que salgan de su zona de confort y que
rompan sus moldes porque solo así se van
a dar cuenta de lo que son realmente no
sólo que los moldes de la sociedad les
dicen que son ustedes son mucho más
salgan de su burbuja de su zona de
confort y vean qué es lo que hay adentro
de ustedes aunque de miedo y las
personas que no levantaron la mano
pónganse en el lugar de sus compañeros
que si la levantaron vean por lo que
piensan por lo que pasa qué es lo que
está sucediendo en sus mentes sólo así
vamos a poder hacer una sociedad más
inclusiva una sociedad donde todos
podemos ser nosotros mismos y ser la
persona que queremos ser los dejo con lo
que dijo la escritora de poeta el a
wheeler wilcox no existe mayor
satisfacción que mirar hacia atrás y
darse cuenta de que uno ha crecido en
autocontrol criterio generosidad y
acciones desinteresadas
me gustaría público que cada uno de
ustedes que yo incluida podamos sentir
lo que dice la persona
la señorita en la volver wilcox pero
sólo lo podemos hacer si salimos de
nuestra burbuja y rompemos los moldes
que nos han hecho sólo así podremos ser
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos
gracias
[Aplausos]